d'accord bien plus qu'un budget car le
cas et en politique on va vous faire
l'interview mensonge en mousse pas il ya
budget encore nombreuses c'est richard
qu'un boucher dont j'ai la bouche a
lancé larouche andré moi je me répète je
vous avoue j'ai dit oui même tu sais
trop ce que je voulais dire un truc
c'est que je me permets mais je vous en
prie le tas pour ça oui
ce monsieur c'est pas une parle non non
non la première fois que j'entends un
homme politique d'hier ces connards et
tout homme politique alors interview
mensonges de jean-louis prolongé de près
il faut répondre sans dire la vérité
sans dire la vérité
un entraînement ma mère qui va tout
comprendre est ce que vous croyez avoir
un avenir politique attend que je dise
linverse de la vérité à mon sens oui
est-ce que vous pensez que berrou et
tous de blasi en avenir national
alors ils peuvent se pacser oui ouais
est ce que chirac est le meilleur
président qui ait eu la vème république
elle en a une autre jospin la gauche
morale ouais est ce que vous trouvez
qu'il est entouré de gens honnêtes et
irréprochable au neutre globalement oui
non là c'est moi mais je me suis
longtemps plantes et non bah vous avez
déjà prôné le fisc non oui mais ceux ci
ils n'arrivent pas à mentir j'embrasse
exa primaire qu'à l'air malin c'est un
vrai plagiat l'air est-ce que vous avez
déjà trompé votre maîtresse
oui j'ai pas de maîtresse
est-ce que vous fréquentez toujours les
boîtes échangistes
oui oui comment lesquels oui vraiment
oui est-ce que vous filmez toujours
autour de pétards avant d'aller à
l'assemblée nationale oui bon ben voila
et labels marocains au maroc est
d'accord pour mettre à dire qu'à moi
mais si je fais plus que du marocain
nareva lumière